shortly after Joe Biden won and it looked
like control of the U.S. Senate was going
to come down to two seats in Georgia.
We knew that the best case scenario was 50/50,
with Democrats technically having a majority
because Kamala Harris gets to cast the tie,
breaking 51 votes.
If all 50 Democrats are on the same page about
a particular issue or bill or whatever the
case may be.
And so when we knew that that was going to
be the scenario, I started talking about Joe
Manchin and as the most conservative Democratic
senator in the U.S. Senate, I said back in
November, December, Joe Manchin could be a
formidable impediment to Joe Biden getting
things done that he claims that he wants to
do.
And my audience was split.
Some in my audience understood the magnitude
of it.
They understood why I was talking about Joe
Manchin.
Some denied it and said Joe Manchin is not
going to really be that big of an obstacle.
As we are clearly seeing now with Joe Manchin
opposed to so much of what Joe Biden wants
to do, we realize that he is indeed a formidable
obstacle.
And now on top of this, we're learning something
about why and it's absolutely horrifying.
In an interview with CNN over the weekend,
Senator Joe Manchin straight up says the January
6th Trump riots made him realize that we need
bipartisanship and we need to placate the
rioters with what he correctly says in this
clip that I'm going to play for you, that
he was shocked by the direct attack on the
basic institutions of government and democracy
on January 6th, as we all should have been
and many of us were.
But Joe Manchin says it made him decide he
needs to seek bipartisanship, period.
He can't just go along with whatever Joe Biden
wants to do, the violence and what is essentially
the terrorism, the hostage taking.
It worked in exactly the way that the terrorists
wanted.
He is saying when terrorists hold me hostage,
I negotiate with them, listen to him, and
then we're going to talk about it more.
January six changed me and I was very clear
with everybody I never thought in my life,
I never read in history books to where our
form of government had been attacked at our
seat of government, which is Washington, DC
and our capital by our own people.
Now, the British did it, but not Americans.
So something told me, wait a minute, pause.
Hit the pause button.
Something's wrong.
You can't have this many people split to where
they want to go to war
with each other.
Can you imagine Joe Manchin now stands in
the way of much of what Joe Biden wants to
do because he wants.
Bipartisanship, thanks to people who stormed
the Capitol and did violence and committed
crimes and wanted the loser, Donald Trump,
to be installed as president.
That's what they wanted, completely anti-democratic,
completely against the law, completely against
everything the country supposedly stands for,
whether Joe Manchin intends to or not, whether
Joe Manchin realizes it or not, he is encouraging
them to do it again.
The reaction to the violent riots should not
be you know, that really shocked me that they
were willing to do that.
So I'm going to be more bipartisan and play
to their side so that we don't have as big
of a disagreement in this country between
right and left.
That's the wrong reaction.
He is playing to those who rioted, saying,
I will now vote in the Senate in a different
way.
That will be closer to what those who rioted,
what the reaction should be.
Those who rioted should be held accountable.
There should be consequences rather than rewards.
He's talking about rewarding them.
We must not give the impression that what
they did on January 6th is valid political
speech or activism.
If you do what they did on January 6th, they
should get nothing from Joe Manchin or anybody.
You should be invalidating voices that use
crime to get their points across.
And yet Joe Manchin is saying, you know, the
riders made me realize we're too divided.
So, you know, I'm not going to go with stuff
Joe Biden wants.
If there isn't Republican support, what what
he wants to bridge the gap between the rioters
and the non rioters.
Give me a break, Joe.
The primary take away from January 6th is
that we have to protect the country from the
influence of people who are willing to do
what the rioters did.
We should be giving them no role in policy
or governance whatsoever not to cater to them.
This is backwards logic from Joe.
It's not even logic.
Quite right.
I don't know what it's there's no logic here.
It changed him.
He says apparently for the worse, they intimidated
him and it worked.
He should be recommitting to only consider
the ideas of non rioters.
It's a completely bizarre argument and reaction.
They were trying to kill him.
And his reaction is, let me let me give them
more of what they want after 9/11.
Should we have said, you know, we maybe we
should look at giving al-Qaida some stuff?
I don't know.
I mean, they were really angry and so they
did 9/11.
Maybe that anger means we should give them
some stuff.
It's backwards.
So that's Joe Manchin giving us now a framework.
We've been wondering, you know, what is it
with Joe Manchin?
This is we now understand the framework under
which Joe Manchin is operating in the Senate.
I don't know how you work with a guy like
that.
And, you know, I know that we often have this
debate.
Well, just primary Joe Manchin and like, put
Bernie Sanders in.
I don't think Bernie Sanders wins in West
Virginia.
I think you just get a Republican.
It's about we have to look at other places.
I mean, short primary Manchin if you want
it.
But if you successfully do, it might lead
to a Republican.
But at the same time, we have to be looking
at states, races in which in twenty twenty
two, a Republican senator can be removed and
a Democratic senator can be put in, hopefully
one who is more reliable vote than Joe Manchin
has been.
Let me know what you think.
This strikes me as could not possibly be more
backwards.
Find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Let me know your thoughts.